the Joe Rogan experience there's a boy
there's a poor wall there but it really
is an important border wall are you
getting a boat you bro over there
it takes three minutes well he can
parkour okay I recently posted up a
bunch of videos of people park chorong
over that wall I saw it yeah look I
admire ingenuity I admire people that
find solutions to problems watching that
guy scale that goddamn wall like Batman
yeah it's amazing
yeah they're coming up with weird wastes
like I saw some people using powdered
titanium to to melt the bars on on one
of the slats
how did titanium again I had to research
it basically it's a powder titanium
prince at a very high rate and when you
start it it's kind of hard to put it out
so they made a whole one and this wall
wood powder type some sort of powder
titanium mix that's like that [ __ ] what
was that [ __ ] that they were talking
about with 9/11 where all the conspiracy
theorists thought that it melted steel
goddamn it pirate a tenner something
like that all right
we're just popped in my head oh yeah
that's the one yeah I feel like that's
the stuff they blow [ __ ] up with right
now they sell these things they call
breech bends like and they there's
there's the four tactical applications
of these pens that B sticks that you
start and you can burn chains open stuff
like that with them really yeah so it's
basically a ghetto version of that is
what they're using you know in some of
these places I know they I mean the wall
as they're making it and speaking to
some of the Border Patrol agents that I
that I know it does a job at as far as
slowing people down so there's not an
overflow of people coming yeah it's not
like what would happen if it was that
that's all night Banzai yeah what would
happen if everybody if there was no
border everybody's like five Mexico's
United States United States is Mexico
have a good time yeah it would be
chaotic of course how long ten years I
don't know how long I mean once
everybody got in yeah I would mean that
other people go there yeah I mean if
what if the United States and Mexico
came to a deal and they said yes yeah
wasn't there a thing that they were
gonna do
there was a North American agreement
there was like they were trying to do
that with the United States
and set up a single currency yes yeah
it's a lot of conspiracy theories around
the Amero yeah that's something like
that we're gonna do it with Canada we're
all gonna become Wayne you see I could
see what Canada yeah but maybe not you
know Mexico well look we're gonna spread
all the good around yeah and then also
like look Mexico's got some awesome
spots wouldn't be great if US industry
moved in there and lithium yeah
well Colombia did a great job in
eradicating all the the problems with
narcotics I think it is well not all
because it still had a gorilla gorilla
group down there that recently the FARC
it went amnesty and then they got active
again but there's still there's still a
lot of cocaine being produced there oh
yeah yeah but it's not nothing like
whenever no what did they do well they
were facing just just a few criminal
groups large ones and Mexico is facing a
lot of them that's interesting they have
the u.s. right next door that is pumping
money into the issue directly didn't
have to fly in no yeah it's not a long
plane flight it's a short walk how so
Mexico is a pretty big country I think
people kind of missed that also it's a
pretty big pretty big country do you
remember when there was a CIA drug plane
that had like several tons of cocaine on
it and it crashed cuz the Mexican
government wouldn't let them land and
refuel yeah yeah I mean all sorts of
conspiracy theories that was a real CIA
drug plane that had been to Guantanamo
Bay at least twice yeah like it was
documented yeah and they for whatever
reason I mean flying back with a lot of
coke living all that coke
I imagine imagine government groups
everywhere have a voice yeah yeah you
have Cowboys when people try to say the
CIA brings in drugs no no people who
work for the CIA
realize they can make a shitload of
money if they bring in drugs and they
pass that money around and they work it
out but the CIA itself does not bring in
drugs yeah customers Customs and Border
Protection agent agent sand just
homeland security as an agency has the
most corruption charges
more enforcement agencies is it really a
federal federal charges for corruption
because they are on border and money
other were of course that's that's why
right it totally makes sense and you
know I mean it maybe it was the CIA guy
that said you know could make some money
through here I mean that was the whole
Barry seals thing that Tom Cruise movie
I mean it was it called made in America
I think I made in America that was about
bringing in drugs with the with Cowboys
that work for the CIA
yeah I mean when I was working down
there in New Mexico and I got to see
different agencies that we would work
with all of a sudden we're like hey can
you guys just go like look over there or
just blue or they're like what's going
on and you would see like some sort of
know what's going on you know but
Cleveland's plane takes off hey there's
nothing nobody saw nothing you know
money exchanges and just you know that's
in you're just an agent you know she's
in the background well that's the thing
that's so scary about what's going on
with the cartels is that the quantity of
money is so extraordinary yeah it's
almost like they can do anything yeah I
mean they have their own cell phone
networks in some places what yeah this
involved that would be good if I knew
but their coverage they have pretty good
coverage in their areas I mean they
dismantled some cell phone networks in
the past also like whole cities with
hidden cameras that are cartel
controlled to see who kills in and out
of the of the towns Wow
like so sophisticated oh yeah so the
Mexicans Mexican government is working
with uniformed agents patrolling and
pickup trucks in the back and these guys
are living in 2025 and using drones to
to surveil the patrols in the area and
they're using their own cell phone
network so they don't have to be worried
about government tapping into their
communications they're utilizing
encrypted phone technology that is
available now commercially throughout
the world
to get around some of these things and
and they're in there working they're
constantly evolving and how they were
you know I remember the first time I was
working in Baja and all the cartel guys
were we move around in Suburbans
dressed like federal agents and they
would look exactly like the legit
federal agents or they were federal
agents with the cartel guys so you would
oh my god so they'd be together
yeah and then we started working with
the military and the military didn't
give a [ __ ] who you were it would stop
everybody she would everybody and the
guys immediately say oh now we're using
taxicabs to move around and different
types of cars and we're gonna paint the
the the vans like taxi vans or we're
gonna move around in ambulances so they
changed their tactics so we were always
after these convoys of Suburbans and now
they're doing something else so that's
how they evolve they just you know
you're trying to go after it with a
hammer and these guys whiskey toes does
it make you want to move to Canada
furthest you can get away from all the
chaos you know must be going on up there
as well right they know suburbs so I
interviewed a smuggler a coyote for one
of the articles I wrote and he you know
asked him directly like what do you
think about the the border wall and the
immigration policies of this current
administration it's good for business
you know it makes it seem like it's
harder to put people in the United
States so I mean that wall is pretty
hard like how do you do it I fly them to
Canada and they walk down well we talked
about it before that the border the
United States is a wall to Mexico the
border from the United States to Canada
is a giant clearing that's a hundred
yards wide it's real clear you can see
it's almost like they make it easy hey
just go right here yeah I mean a lot of
people that want to get to the into u.s.
here you hear numbers from $8,000 to
$15,000 depending on who you are what
you're trying to do how you're trying to
get up here as far as being smuggled up
and he's like past Mexican Passport
get a Mexican passport if you're Mexican
get you a Mexican Passport
we'll put $2,000 in an accountant
somewhere so if they want to verify if
you're just financially solvent they
will check that and just fly to Canada
and just walk down and that's what we do
[Applause]